hello everyone and welcome to day two of
the finals uh between eleven iron and
tamara java rajaba one
uh game one after the first three games
ended in android jabber won the fourth
game
and now uh we need a win from 11 to get
back into the match so let's see what
happens here 11 has the white pieces and
this is already
uh a complete and utter madness uh you
know
starting with game one so eleven opens
with e4
we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6
and now bishop to c4 ah the italian game
is on the board and now bishop to c5
and yes i know you guys are really eager
to see if
b4 was played in this position but no 11
did not go for the evans game but
unfortunately he played c3
and now knight to f6 uh so just
continuing with the main line of the
joko piano we have d3
and now both players castle so castles
castles and the d6 so a nice symmetrical
position
has been played a million times bishop
to g5
now developing the bishop pinning that
knight and now h6
uh rajav pushes the bishop back bishop
h4 and even
g5 here uh with bishop captures even
though there are some lines where you
can even sacrifice the knight here but
it's uh pretty much a a force to draw in
this level of competition so bishop back
to g3
and now a5 by rajabov we have rook to e1
and now there is one in game in the
database where g4 was played but here we
have rook to e8 by rajab
and it is already as of move tender we
have a completely new game
so here knight b to d2 preparing the
standard maneuver knight f1 is coming to
e3
bishop back to a7 you don't want that d4
uh push when it happens to come with an
attack on the bishop so bishop back to
a7
and now knight to f1 with bishop to e6
offering a trade and 11 keeps the
pressure on the board just uh
re-maneuvering the bishop to b5
now not allowing this knight to move so
bishop back to d7
and only now knight to a3 so at some
point this knight might come to f5
uh we have knight the e7 now offering a
trade of light square bishops and levin
defends it with
a4 so here while you can uh for example
capture and
double up uh white's b pawns you also
give
the white rook a semi-open a file so not
something you want to do so after this
a4 move
rajab has to decide whether whether he
wants to capture for example on e3 where
he wants to
play something like c6 and kick away
this bishop whether he wants to improve
the position of the king
and this is the first time in the in the
game that rajabov took
i think maybe like a minute and a half
and he played c6 so he kicked away the
bishop
bishop the c4 and now knight the g6 and
here 11's move is
very very instructive uh the movie plays
next is queen to c2
and this is something you should always
remember whenever your opponent
advances his pawns in front of the king
like this and his bishop
your own bishop for example is spinning
the f7 pawn then
if this queen ever captures the knight
the pawn will not be able to capture
back so queen c2
with the idea of some pawn advancements
in the center so
for a moment the position in the center
is closed but if the pawns move forward
then queen captures on g6
uh is a very big threat so here knight
to f4 by rajabov he gets
that knight into a much more active
square and rook
8 to d1 everything is getting ready for
that
d4 thrust uh so queen to e7 or java
develops the queen connects the rooks
and now
finally d4 by 11. we have e
captures on d4 and now bishop captures
on f4 it's important to eliminate the
defender of the g6 square
so 11 captures it we have g captures and
here comes eleven's
idea e5 and now uh as we can see this
uh here um bishop is still on this
diagonal and queen to g6 is the threat
as black will not be able to capture
back
and now what do you play here well here
uh rojava played
d captures an e3 which is not the
absolute best move
i'm just going to show you the absolute
best move because it's super complicated
but it's actually d3
and it's uh for a rapid game you you
simply do not
see this the point is uh you want to
close off this diagonal for the moment
force the white queen to capture and
only now capture on f3
and now you are nicely threatening uh to
capture here with
check as the bishop defends this pawn
and after this uh queen g6 check you're
gonna play king to h8
captures with check knight h7 and now
the point is
after a move let's say f captures an e3
now you play d5
and the point is after bishop to d3 as
this was all
uh white's plan all along now you can
play f5 and
after e captures on f6 alpha trying to
get the queen to capture the checkmate
the black king
now you have this queen captures an e3
check and that's the whole point
rook captures bishop captures with check
white also has to give up the queen and
after captures and captures
black is up a whole rook and completely
winning
but kind of a lot to see in a rapid game
you know
in in a minute or two so uh rajava
played the next best
thing the captures on e3 and now he
allows queen to g6
with check king the h8 and now queen
captures with
check knight blocking with h7 and now 11
just
attacks the knight and threatens
checkmate bishop to d3 is now
threatening checkmate
uh and here rajabo has to figure out
does he block checkmate how
how does he block checkmate can he even
blocks uh checkmate
or does he just plays uh play e captures
and f2 with check and win material
so if there's nothing wrong with it you
should always capture material and then
defend
unless you know it loses on the spot so
here rajabo first captures on f2 with
check king to f1 and now he grabs the
rook
again with check and here we've reached
the position from the thumbnail
where black momentarily has two queens
on the board but it doesn't help him all
that much since rook captures on e1
and now you're still uh you know getting
checkmated here so how do you defend
this
uh f5 is one move you can play but uh
instead of f5 or jabba finds the very
result a resourceful bishop to f5 he
wants to get
the bishop away from the defense of the
c4 square he wants to have
uh the ability to to get his queen there
as uh he is planning to bring his queen
to f7 and then to c4 to come with
check so that's why the this uh well
pretty pretty crazy bishop sacrifice so
here 11 accepts it
still threatening checkmate and now f6
uh the queen now defends against
checkmate e captures on f6
now the queen again cannot capture
you're getting checkmated so queen to f7
and now we see
the idea behind our job of bishop to f5
move he wants to have this
this option of playing queen to c4 with
check uh and here levin
started bringing his rook up the board
and uh well had he captured on e8 he
probably would have won the game but he
actually played
rook to e8 and a lot of people thought
this was a mouse slip
but as it turns out it it wasn't as
eleven played it
instantly and it does come with the idea
of bringing the knight to g5
uh however rajavov simply captured it
with rook captures and now
knight to g5 the knight cannot capture
there's now a triple attack on the
knight
also the black queen is under attack
there's a monster fork here
so uh rajabao's next move is forced and
he has to give up the queen so
rook captures on f6 was played knight
captures wit
check rook captures and then now comes a
bishop captures an h7
rook captures and now queen to f6 with
check
uh and here as you can see rajabo has
two rooks and the bishop for a queen and
he is better in this position but it's
very hard to wiggle out
the king away from that corner as
rajabov has
merely seconds on the clock so not rook
g7 king to g8 was played
uh we have queen to g6 check and now a
series of
checks occurred rook g7 queen to e6
check
rook f7 queen to g6 back with check and
now rojo either has to block or move the
king he decides to move the king which
gives up
uh yet another pawn so maybe not uh the
best thing to do but rajavo just wants
to get out of checks if he can get that
rook into the game
uh he should be he should be winning
this so king g7
queen back to e5 check king g6 queen e6
checking g7 25 check king to g6
quinta e6 with check king g7 and queen
e5 check and it was in this position
that uh not only did the players agree
to draw but it was actually a three-fold
repetition that occurred so
of course the game ended in a draw but
really really insane stuff uh
11 really producing uh almost a
masterpiece here with
that brilliant attack but yeah that's
something you should always look for in
your own games when you have this
option of let me just rewind that for a
little bit when you see black placing uh
for example or white his pieces like
this where you have this
option of going after that knight then
always
imagine things that maybe you know even
though they are very far away maybe
maybe it can happen maybe you can move
some pawns
and then the the idea becomes possible
so this 11 did here
and he played a brilliant attack and it
almost
won him the game but our job of uh
defense proved to be
very sturdy and he was not able to to
push it all the way so we'll see what
happens game one ends in a draw
and three more games to go uh will
eleven equalize or and will we go into
tie breaks
or will rajavo simply win it all uh so
yeah
that's game one i hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank
jamal nazi uh linus domin uh domanskis
uh raymond letta
eric rodovic and brian hoffaker for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh with the coverage of the
finals checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens uh
in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day